this wriggling little guy is a baby bruh
coned wasp it's bursting out of a
Cottonwood dagger caterpillar and
starting to spin a cocoon believe it or
not this somewhat gruesome scene is part
of a healthy balanced ecosystem until
now the caterpillar served as the WAAFs
food and nursery rekon eduardo a suit
ides that means they first infect but
eventually kill their host animals to
survive regular parasites generally
don't kill their hosts outright the
cycle begins when a parasitoid lays eggs
inside or on the caterpillar or on top
of the caterpillars food as the larvae
hatch and grow they feed on the
caterpillars internal organs they often
save the most important parts for last
to keep their hosts alive some
parasitoids like this tak net fly grow
to nearly the same size as their hosts
before bursting out after emerging from
the caterpillar these parasitoids pupate
and develop into adults then they search
for a new host to lay eggs
starting with cycle over parasitoids
have a special purpose they keep their
host populations in check
without them the caterpillar population
could skyrocket out of control and
destroy the trees that they eat
some parasitoids are used to help
control invasive species and pests that
otherwise could devastate the
environment so they can help keep the
ecosystem healthy sometimes helpful
things come in wriggling packages
[Music]